- Thank you Irene.
Dr. David Poulin is a physicist
whose research focuses
primarily on finding efficient,
effective methods to
protect quantum information
and this is of course an anticipation
of the quantum computing revolution
that's already begun
where quantum computing
devices will change
the face of computation as we know it.
Protecting information in that area
is not surprisingly gonna
be as much of a challenge
as it is today.
And the fact that CIFAR
provides opportunities
for young researchers to mix
with experienced members in their field,
led Dr. Poulin to a situation a while ago.
Rarely afforded young researchers
at a CIFAR meeting he said
some provocative things
about quantum mechanics
which prompted a challenge
from a Nobel Laureate.
I wasn't there.
Dr. Poulin apparently responded directly
and survived and he's now co-director
of the Quantum Information
Science program.
Please welcome Dr. David Poulin.
(crowd clapping)
- Thank you Jay for the introduction.
So, I'm gonna describe to you
what my day in the office looks like.
There you go.
So, when I come in my office
and let's say I don't have
any pressing obligations,
I like to just stand at the board
and scribble some equations
and these help me come up
with new quantum software.
So, this is what my board
looked like earlier this week.
In this example,
I was considering a very common task
in machine learning called
stochastic gradient descent.
We're using a lot of computer power
to solve that particular problem currently
and I was trying to figure out
if this problem could benefit
from a quantum computer
if we could accelerate this and I failed,
I haven't succeeded,
but I have a couple of
other tricks down my sleeve
and this is just one of many problems
that keep me busy.
But over the years
I have designed a few quantum algorithms,
a few piece of quantum software
that should enable a
future quantum computer
to solve certain computational problems
in a time that is very reasonable,
but that currently cannot be solved
even with the world's
largest supercomputer.
So, if we succeed one day in
building a quantum computer,
some of the software I came up with
could be used to understand
some complex molecular reaction
or maybe some piece of quantum material
or advanced material
and this in turn could
turn into new drug design
or new energy transport.
I don't know.
And honestly,
I don't really care.
You see, when I do research,
I'm not by these potential applications.
I just wanna understand
the fundamental power
that quantum mechanics
offers in terms of computing.
And sometimes I work on a problem
and I realize that this
problem cannot possibly benefit
from a quantum computational speed up.
And this might be surprising to you,
but in terms of personal fulfillment,
this is equally rewarding
as finding a new application
because in both case,
I learned something new
about quantum mechanics.
So, I think this is possibly the hallmark
of intellectual freedom.
It's having the luxury or the freedom
or the privilege of asking a question
without a priori,
any preference
or what the answer should be.
We just wanna know the answer.
So, of course coming up
with new quantum software
and new quantum algorithms
requires some technical
skills and knowledge.
You need to understand how
a quantum computer operates
and what are the underlying
logic quantum information.
But I think that
by far the most important
ingredient is creative thinking.
So, you have to take a problem
that we use computers to solve
and understand the
mathematical structure of it,
and try to understand how
you can grab this problem
and make it amenable
to a quantum computer.
(clears throat)
So, in fact,
the creative thinking is
not only important today,
the very idea of building
a quantum computer began
when a few very marginal researchers
had the courage of asking
a very bold question.
The the question they
ask is the following,
quantum mechanics is this
very counterintuitive theory
that explains the atomic
and subatomic world.
"So, how can quantum mechanics change
"the way in which we exchange
"and process information?"
So, to understand just how
crazy this question is,
you need to know that
quantum mechanics at always
been restricted to the atomic scale, okay.
You don't need quantum mechanics
to explain how a tennis
ball will bounce around
or how airplanes fly.
These are explained by
Newtonian classical mechanics.
So, suggesting that a human scale system
like a computer could
utilize the strange features
of the quantum universe was delusional
when it was first suggested in the 1980s.
Yet today we have major
corporations, government
and venture capitalists
investing billions of dollars
to build a quantum computer.
This picture shows IBM's latest attempt.
You can even play with it.
You could access it on
the cloud if you'd like.
So, of course these industrial players
are primarily interested in
harnessing... in harvesting,
sorry,
the tremendous computational power
of quantum information,
but they also recognize that
without intellectual freedom,
this power would never
have been unleashed.
Okay.
So, organizations like CIFAR
help us stay vigilant
at protecting our right
to ask very tricky and risky questions.
And our CIFAR program,
the Quantum Information Science program
has been largely shaped by
another very risky question.
The question is,
what do we learn about fundamental physics
by thinking about physical systems,
whether it's an airplane,
this remote or a black hole
or whatnot as an
information processing unit?
So, this may sound like a strange question
and it deserves explanation.
So, of course we're used
to think of information
as something immaterial.
Think about the password to my smartphone.
This has nothing to do
with physics, does it?
But the reality is that
any information requires
a physical system,
whether it's my brain,
a hard drive in my phone
or ink on a piece of paper,
there can be no information
without physical support.
And this has consequences.
So, to give you a simple example,
you know that no physical
body can travel faster
than the speed of light.
Therefore, a consequence is that
you cannot send information,
information cannot be transmitted faster
than the speed of light
because information needs to be supported
by physical system.
So, this is an example of how
the laws of physics impose
constraints on the laws
and the rules of information.
But what we like to do now is
turn this picture around and say,
"How do the rules of
information processing affect
"the universe in which we live?"
The upshot of this is that
information is universal.
So, if you discover that
there's a fundamental limit
on some information processing task,
this puts a limit of physical
and constraint on every
possible embodiment
of that information.
So, information theory is really universal
and it cuts across physics.
So, you could be studying,
say electronic correlation
in a piece of superconductor,
and you discover a new
information pattern there,
and you can transpose
this information pattern
to something like a black hole
and learn entire new physics there.
And I'm not just saying that
because that example I just gave
was one of the crown achievement
of our CIFAR program
in the past five year.
We took the knowledge we
have of quantum information
to shed new light on some
of the deepest questions
in physics including the black
hole evaporation paradox.
This is where the two pillars
of modern physics quantum mechanics
and general relativity collide.
So, enough may be about
these achievements.
So, you all know that
information technologies
have transformed our
society in very deep way.
It's also transformed the
way we pursue knowledge.
And I believe that this
trend will continue.
I wouldn't be surprised that soon
the information theoretic
perspective will affect many
if not all areas of science,
and maybe it will even blur
the boundary between
scientific disciplines.
The way we currently organize the research
is by saying,
"Oh, this is humanity,
"this is life science,
"this is physical science,
but maybe in the future,
"we will organize research in terms of
"what information processing
"is this research concerned with."
So, here's maybe some information,
some correlation structure
that shows up in the human genome
and the same pattern
shows up in economics.
So, these people should
be working together
because in terms of
information perspective,
they're working on the same problem.
So, you might think that
this kind of idea sounds completely crazy
but that's precisely why I'm here.
So, thank you,
(crowd laughs)
and have a good evening.